men what percent from your personal
experience and your friends experiences
um what percent of women require men to
wear condoms what percentage yeah what
percentage
in this day and age you know
i've heard many people tell me
they didn't even need to ask and i've
i've actually had a friend that said
that they just the girl slipped in
yeah girl said
so it's like
yeah but then to be fair there's a lot
more women on birth control
compared to before on it so that might
be another percentage-wise though do you
want a pacific number like that yeah
like would you say 10 20 50 80 percent
maybe four around forty percent i'd say
maybe
diseases
because i feel because
women are mostly kind of majority might
be chasing that top
top top guy in it so they might not even
care
um
yeah so
yeah it would be a small it'd be a small
amount
of women
because not yeah they they choose who
they
anyone say over 50 percent
so women why do you
why do you think women in general are so
reckless with their sexual health
i didn't know that
because this is actually high numbers
most shows i've
i've gotten lower when i've asked this
question
i would say the average i've heard from
guys was like 10 to 20 percent like 40
that's the highest percentage i've
gotten
one of my best well my best friend is a
is a male and he went um
not in hill carnival
he said
one thing that stood out to me said he
went around the corner of a girl
beautiful girl he showed me a picture of
her beautiful girl went around the
corner had a quickie oh wow no in the
carnival in the carnival
no uh contraception nothing they just
did it did it and then left and
obviously
oh okay yeah she got his number he's got
his number and everything i heard vice
versa whatever but
if it's like that in carnival god bless
you more
they're just mad that's crazy
wait where like where did they go
behind someone's house there's many
places there's many places
i went to do the interviews but like
there's people everywhere they don't
care they don't care
there's loads of you know what's that
at the moment
i don't know i'll do a carnival like i
just i went to watch it i went to my
first one to do interviews but i was i
didn't you seen it you wouldn't see it
because it's quick
i would be scarred for life i think this
is saying uh sometimes the best way to
hide something is to do it in the open i
don't know
[Laughter]
and then they just get videos like put
on like twitter or something
you know if someone captured it
yeah
wait does that is carnival like crazy
here yes yes
you haven't seen anything you need to go
back
i saw the crazy outfits but i didn't
really we're just like did you get it in
the crowd
oh okay i'll tell you what happened so
hi
i've heard okay i've heard a lot about
carnival and everyone i've never been to
a festival before so this was like an
interesting like first one to go to and
um so when i went i did the interviews
and i always asked like what on earth
would you do for eight hours straight
like i just in my brain like it doesn't
compute like what are you and everyone
says just vibes and i was like what does
that even mean
like i don't understand what like vibing
like like is that you just chilling just
just having fun just like following the
floats
i think i think i'm just like mentally
an old person i don't know
and um so the last hour i was like okay
i'm going to try the vibes
so i was like i told my camera man i was
like you can go home you know oh yeah
because it was like there's like an hour
left in carnival so i was like i did my
interviews let me see and
i was it was horrible
like one i got in this like i wanted to
leave like at the end and i got in this
crowd and there's people everywhere and
then people try to grab you i'm like no
yeah well guys not trying to touch you
up and just yeah they weren't yeah
stubborn no no no you vibe you gotta
vote that's the vibe
it's too hard though
and you can't even run away
because you're just like
but i was just trying to leave and it
was like then i ended up by this like
parade thingy and oh my gosh it was it
was a lot but that was only an hour so i
can't even imagine how people do
like a full day
but i think the girls they come blind
they just banova start twitching right
when they get grabbed that's why guys
touch you up because they think you're
gonna that's the other thing they they
like yeah they were strangers yeah and i
was so confused i'm like do you people
know each other it's very weird like
black people why do you do that i know
it's
a culture
there was this video uh daily mail where
this guy was twerking on the policeman
yeah and a guy was grinding on the
policewoman as well like i'm saying
what's going on if you if you understand
the character of the police woman if you
understand the caribbean
you understand that it's it may not look
what it's actually harmless yeah that's
just how we move that's how we are yeah
so more time more times than not when
you come to carnival you come with a
mindset that that's going to happen yeah
there's a lot of sex going on
how is it harmless if the dude like took
the girl behind the you're telling me
people are having sex everywhere no no
no no no no
no no no no i'm talking about the vibes
inside that there is a lot of him in it
but normally when you go to carnival
it's like example if you go to certain
places in the caribbean listen to their
music and dance with it it's a lot of
it's a lot of provocative dancing but if
you have that mindset that you're gonna
you're gonna go there some people wanna
dance with you that's normally what yeah
tends to happen but there's some there's
some people that go overboard we can we
can admit that but doesn't it all end up
in sex if it's not this moment the
exchange number it'll be later it's a
lot of sexual attention
not always
well if the girl is attractive and she
makes you excited she's supposed to be
here but
it's right by the end of the day not
every every man from there thinks okay
i'm gonna have sex with you good
question okay since it's harmless
are you guys cool dancing with like a 60
year old lady a six-year-old lady yeah
yeah because it's harmless it's not
sexual yeah if she's if she's dead so be
honest if you if she was or a lizzo
sized lady nope no no
and when you talk about a six-year-old
woman that has nothing to do with the
action that's to do with my me wanting
to dance with her
what i'm saying so let me say you're
harmless i'm talking about if it's
harmless are you gonna latch your
grandma
remember harmless
that's what this no but you need to
remember what harmless means it means
without harm so i can dance with lizzo
and a six-year-old and she doesn't get
hurt at all that's harmless me not
wanting to dance does not mean harm is
there a sexual undertone to it though
that's what we're trying to ask
in some cases there is in some cases in
all of the cases is sexual why would you
do
that
that's the point that's the point we're
making yeah so
when i when you said when you said
harmless like i was just interpreting
that as like it's not sexual so i
understand like most dancing no one's
getting hurt yeah like most interesting
but the reason why i say that is because
there's a lot of cultures outside of the
caribbean that wouldn't dance that way
so when they see our thoughts that way
there already is a negative connotation
to it yeah but if you are part of our
culture you understand what that means
okay maybe harmless wasn't the right
word yeah but a lot of so the way how we
dance it may not lead to anything sexual
after that maybe just that dance are you
wife so you cool with like wife and a
girl that goes to carnival every year
and does the full two days no would you
it's
[Laughter]
no no no this is just what she's been
doing the harmless harmless
last last couple years before she met
you
don't change it don't change it you're
not there this is before she met you
yeah so you were you didn't know her
she's been going to carnival she tells
you yeah i've been here for five years
vibes personally i would okay if she's
caribbean like me i would okay
but if she's she's not caribbean does it
change it it depends on how well she
understands the caribbean culture and
carnival okay
only because it's great because like
because because because i am jamaican
i understand that that form of dancing
so maybe harmless may not be the right
word to to have used yeah but
i have danced so me personally i've
danced with many girls in that way and
once we finished we went our separate
ways right so i'm saying
you go to your girl to the carnival yeah
you're okay for a guy to dance like no
it's harmless
no the reason why the reason why is
because navajos are single
so it's more of a single right but you
don't accidentally it's more of a single
thing i don't think they go around in
carnival asking are you single no okay
let's dance
yeah it's like if you're not yeah
but a joke if you're not single you
should know not to dance with anyone
else right
it depends on something i think when you
were saying that it's harmless it's like
andy doesn't like to anything right he
doesn't always because you can dance
like that with your friends yeah that's
what i think he's
harmless like it always
one at a time please yeah so she just
said it leads to something it always
leads something slowly i disagree
because i've danced with friends and
it's never led to anything yeah sure it
doesn't always lead to sex but the
sexual undertone is what we're talking
about there's some there's something
going on if someone if a girl's bomb is
right grinding against my groin it's
there's something going on right always
okay okay i just wish i could pull a
video right now i'm just girls twerking
at carnival and you're telling me
there's no sexual undertaking the dance
alone is sexually sexual
yeah
this is just what i saw
why do you not get hard if it's not
sexual why are you getting hard please
not always
half of the time half of the time that's
because that's because it's someone
you're attracted to but if you're
dancing with someone you're not
attracted to you're not going to get
home but you wouldn't dance with someone
you're not attracted to that's what you
said
as many of you know i was just banned on
tick-tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible